it's not just making an electric car
it's making a system that churns out
huge numbers of electric cars being at a
net worth of 230 billion roughly being
perceived as the richest person on Earth
I'm not sure why he has to also say that
he was a Founder when he wasn't I don't
understand that well and he's the worst
person I have ever worked with and that
is saying something
five people found a Tesla but only one
became a billionaire today Tesla and
Elon Musk are synonymous Elon has led
the company since 2008 and it was under
his leadership that the company evolved
from being a nearly bankrupt startup to
a trillion dollar Automotive giant this
has made Elon the largest shareholder of
Tesla owning a little less than
one-fifth of the company which has made
him the richest man in the world but
Elon wasn't the only key player at Tesla
in fact he wasn't even one of the
original Founders yet he is worth
magnitudes more than any of the other
four Founders only one of the other
Founders JP Straubel has even reached
billionaire status coming in at 1.3
billion dollars but that was one year
ago when Tesla stock was at its peak
since then Tesla stock has sold off 48
so it's unlikely that JB is a
billionaire anymore obviously this this
isn't to say that the other Founders are
not well off given that they're likely
worth tens of millions if not hundreds
of millions but when you compare these
figures to elon's 200 billion dollar
fortunate they're nothing Elon literally
has a daily net worth swings that are
worth more than the net worths of all of
the other Founders combined so why is
Elon Musk the only Tesla co-founder that
became stupid rich
foreign
taking a look back Tesla was originally
founded by two men named Martin Eberhard
and Mark tarponing on July 1st 2003.
Martin served as the CEO of the company
while Marx served as the CFO their dream
was to create a modern technology-based
automotive company with a focus on
batteries computer software and
proprietary Motors but while they had
high Ambitions something that they
didn't have was money if this was an
internet-based company or some sort of
app they may have been able to get away
with it bootstrapping it but given that
this was an automotive company that just
wasn't gonna fly so they would set out
to raise money almost instantaneously
and they would close their series a
round of funding in February of 2004.
they would actually raise a substantial
amount of money coming in at 6.5 million
dollars but almost all of that came from
a single individual investor Elon Musk
according to Elon he invested 6.35
million and Martin invested 75 000. some
other sources actually reported that the
initial funding round was worth seven
and a half million dollars and at that
Compass technology partners and a few
others through in the last million
either way though Elon was by far the
largest investor and he was far from
being done in the meantime Martin and
Mark were building out the initial Tesla
team the first person that they hired
was Ian Wright and a couple of months
later they would hire JB's trouble as
CTO today these five men are the ones
that are credited with the founding
Tesla Elon was definitely an involved
investor from day one as he played an
active role in the development of the
original Tesla Roadster but he wasn't
quite an employee per se given that he
wasn't that involved in the company's
daily activities that didn't really
matter though because by far elon's
largest contribution to Tesla in the
early days was capital and let's just
say he kept the capital flowing about
two years after series a Elon would lead
a series B funding round that ended up
raising at 13 million dollars and it
added a Valor Equity Partners to the
funding team and just four months after
that Elon would co-lead a series C
funding round that raised 40 million
dollars and got many of his Tech friends
involved in Tesla this included the
co-founders of Google Sergey Brennan and
Larry Page as well as the former
president of eBay Jeff skoll Elon would
finally round off all the fundraising
with a fourth round of funding that
raised 45 million dollars these were all
the funding rounds that Elon happily
engaged in but there was actually one
more unexpected round of funding the
dark days of 2008 would force Elon to
put everything else he had into the
company and by by the time the company
got to the other side they had raised a
total of 187 million dollars this marked
the end of elon's personal contributions
and VC funding rounds since then Tesla
has primarily relied on governments
other car companies and the public
investors for Capital and fortunately
none of these have required too much
dilution all of this left Elon with the
ginormous 28.4 stake at IPO meanwhile
the original Founders were essentially
diluted into Oblivion especially because
they weren't able to contribute much to
these funding rounds themselves neither
Martin nor Mark have ever revealed
details regarding their Tesla's data
during this time period but it was
likely in the single digits that's
nothing to scoff at though even a five
percent stake in the company would be
worth 34 billion dollars so how did
Martin and Mark go from being future
DACA billionaires to not even
billionaires well that can be explained
by the ousting of the founders
foreign
musk Fanboys usually like to pretend
that this never happened meanwhile Elon
Musk haters like to frame this as Elon
being a greedy investor who wanted more
power but in reality neither of these
are what really happened the truth was
that Martin and Mark were hitting some
brick walls when it came to running
Tesla and that this was becoming
increasingly apparent Martin had set up
a rather inefficient supply chain that
encompassed three continents first much
of the roadster's ports and materials
were sourced from all over Asia then it
had to be assembled and safety tested in
England and finally it had to be shipped
to North America to be delivered this
was obviously not very efficient and it
made the production cost of the Roadster
far higher than the purchase price
Martin didn't really want to admit this
so he allegedly misled investors
regarding how much the Roadster would
cost to produce Elon claims that Martin
assured him that the Roadster would cost
65 000 after the first 100 units however
knowing how inefficient Tesla supply
chain was Elon was such of these numbers
so he ordered a detailed cost breakdown
of the car and it turned out that it was
closer to a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars apparently even that was being
generous by the time they actually got
past the first 100 units the materials
alone were costing them a hundred and
forty thousand dollars per car for
obvious reasons musk was triggered and
it moved to fire Martin the right way to
approach this situation would have been
to set up a meeting with Martin and hash
out their differences Martin claims that
he was well aware of his shortcomings
and that he himself had brought up the
idea of bringing in a more experienced
CEO to replace him so I'm sure they
could have come to an amicable solution
if they had just set up a meeting but
instead it Elon decided to arrange a
shareholder coup while Martin was
attending a business meeting at outside
the country and Elon wouldn't even
inform Martin until after the deed was
done as you would guess when Martin
heard about this he too was triggered
and that this has led to the great feud
between them ever since apparently Elon
offered Martin a position as an advisor
but it seems that Martin took this as
more of an insult than an opportunity
all of this transpired during the summer
of 2007 and Martin and Mark would vote
to leave Tesla all together at the
beginning of 2008. they would turn
around and Sue Elon for forcing them out
but they would eventually settle the
full details of the settlement were not
revealed but one of the agreements that
they came to was that all of them would
be credited as co-founders of Tesla and
that's how Elon Musk JB Strobel and Ian
Wright officially became co-founders Ian
had already left Tesla on his own will
just one year after joining so he
obviously didn't have a very big stake
in Tesla if any Martin and Mark likely
did though and the only reason they're
not Deca billionaires today is because
they saw the majority of their Stakes
likely out of spite and that leaves us
with the just the JBS trouble and Elon
Musk
elon's aggressive funding rounds no
doubt it played a massive role in his
multi-hundred billion dollar Fortune but
that's not the only ingredient something
else that has put him before ahead of
the other Founders is his aggressive CEO
compensation musk often likes to claim
that his compensation is only one dollar
per year and while that may be
technically true it means absolutely
nothing for someone as rich as Elon no
company can afford to pay him a cash
salary that's worth his time even if a
company paid him a 200 million dollars
per year like Sundar piche it would take
him a thousand years to earn his current
fortune and that's before taxes so the
only way Elon can be compensated is
stock compensation and oh boy his talk
compensation is nuts his latest
Compensation Plan was created in 2018
when Tesla was worth 59 billion dollars
the planet until the Elon getting an
additional one percent of the company
for every 50 billion increment in market
cap to offset for your 4 stock runs like
we saw over the past two years Elon also
has to achieve certain revenue and
earnings Milestones as well for Elon to
unlock the entire compensation which is
worth 12 percent he has to hit a market
cap of 650 billion dollars an annual
revenue of 175 billion dollars and an
adjusted ebitda of 14 billion dollars
Tesla has already achieved a market cap
of 650 billion dollars and an ebitda of
14 billion dollars so Elon just has to
hit the revenue Targets this will
definitely take some time given that
Tesla still has to grow their revenue by
a hundred billion dollars from where
they are today but given their current
trajectory I think it's reasonable to
estimate that they'll Crush that number
by the end of this decade by which point
Elon would have grown his Tesla stake by
a whopping at 12 if Tesla is worth 3
trillion dollars at the time elon's
compensation would have been worth a
mind-boggling 360 billion dollars not to
mention it that'll just keep growing
with time if Tesla does hit a 10
trillion dollar valuation like many
Tesla boards are hoping for elon's
compensation would be worth 1.2 trillion
dollars now you might be wondering how
Tesla Sport approved such a generous
Compensation Plan well while these
numbers are ludicrous from an
individual's perspective they're not
that crazy compared to Tesla's growth
when Elon pitched this idea in 2018 this
is essentially what he was asking for
would it be possible for everyone to
dilute their shares by 12 and to give it
to me if I 13x this company in the
coming years
taking such a deal is a no-brainer if
Elon doesn't hit his goals you don't
even have to pay him if he does hit his
goals though both of you would have
ridiculous gains now of course there are
some shareholders that are mad and have
even filed a lawsuit against Elon and
Tesla but that is definitely the
minority and that brings us back to JB's
trouble even though JB was a Founder he
was never CEO and so he never had access
to such generous compensation
foreign
whether you think it's fair or not the
reason that Elana is a magnitudes richer
than Tesla's other Founders is because
he played his cards extremely well Elon
leveraged his position to the absolute
maximum every step of the way when he
was an investor he led every single
funding round and to put in every penny
he had into the company maximizing his
take then when he became CEO he slashed
his salary to the absolute minimum so
that he can maximize his stock
compensation we should also mention that
elon's current Tesla stake only accounts
for about half of his net worth the rest
of his net worth comes from SpaceX and
potentially Twitter by the time you're
watching this meanwhile the remaining
Tesla Founders never had the leverage of
capital and or they made some missteps
along the way that pushed them out of
the company altogether given their
financial situation they should have
started a much cheaper business if
getting rich was their goal but honestly
I don't think they mind it too much
while they're not billionaires and
definitely not sent to billionaires
there's so done extremely well off and
though they may not be as rich or as
popular as Elon there is no doubt that
their real world impacts are far larger
than what their net worth may suggest do
you think Elon stole Tesla comment that
down below also drop a like if you're
glad that Tesla is doing well and
electrifying the world and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered until then
I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on the
next one